[Música]
en Brasil arrestan al jefe de seguridad
pública de Brasilia y exministro de Yair
bolsonaro por omisión y connivencia
durante el asalto a los edificios de los
poderes públicos el pasado 8 de enero
por otra parte la Corte Suprema acordó
investigar al expresidente por su
presunta participación en los hechos
crece la polémica por el hallazgo de
nuevos documentos clasificados en la
casa del presidente estadounidense Joe
biden en Delaware en menos de una semana
ya se han conocido sobre el
Descubrimiento de tres paquetes de
documentos Tenemos reporte desde
Washington
California continúa siendo afectado por
tormentas que han provocado inundaciones
cortes eléctricos y evacuaciones sin
embargo los habitantes agradecen las
lluvias en un estado que vive constantes
sequías lo que provoca racionamientos de
agua
Hola Bienvenidos a las noticias del
continente americano en France 24 los
saluda Andrés Meza Muñoz empezamos en
Brasil continúa la respuesta contra el
intento de asalto al poder en Brasilia
Anderson Torres ex ministro de Justicia
del país y quien se desempeñaba como
secretario de seguridad de la capital
brasileña en el momento del ataque fue
detenido antes el ex presidente Jair
bolsonaro fue incluido en la
investigación por haber incitado a la
Poderosa extrema derecha del país a
salir a las calles lluís Muñoz tiene más
detalles
este avión aterrizó en Brasilia con
Anderson Torres después fue detenido ex
ministro de Justicia del expresidente
Jair bolsonaro y en el momento del
intento del asalto a los tres poderes
secretario de seguridad de Brasilia es
sospechoso de convivencia con los
violentos y en su casa encontraron una
prueba que evidenciaría la planificación
de los ataques
el documento es como una especie de
eslabón perdido entre una sucesión de
hechos que demuestran que no fueron
casos aislados
antes de la detención la Corte Suprema
había incluido a bolsonaro en la
investigación como posible autor
intelectual este habría incitado
públicamente al fuerte poder de sus
masas de extrema derecha la semana
pasada demostraron tener una capacidad
de convocatoria y de movilización y de
acción violenta sorprendentes quiere
decir esto que todo el lector de
bolsonaro está dispuesto a dar un golpe
de estado o a asaltar y saquear los
principales Palacios públicos no
sin embargo para el analista magnocal
también Habrá más miedo y una mayor
respuesta
había cierta tolerancia hacia los
discursos antidemocráticos pero una vez
que estos discursos se convierten en
acciones la gente Podría tener un poco
más de miedo de hablar o actuar en el
resultado de las elecciones
el 8 de enero miles de personas entraron
en las sedes del poder judicial
ejecutivo y legislativo en Brasilia
provocaron una de las mayores crisis de
las últimas décadas en Brasil desde
entonces ya hay más de 1800 personas
detenidas y siete investigaciones
activas que incluyen políticos y
empresarios
a un año del derrame de más de 11.000
barriles de crudo en las costas de Perú
las playas del distrito de ancón en la
provincia de Lima siguen cerradas ante
la presencia de petróleo lo que ha
impedido que las personas que viven del
mar puedan retomar sus actividades a
pesar de que repsol la empresa
responsable del derrame dijo que ya
están dadas las condiciones de
reactivación de pesca los residentes
locales piden a la compañía que actúe
con rapidez y compense a todos los
afectados se espera que este domingo se
lleve a cabo un plantón con motivo del
aniversario
el gobierno del presidente colombiano
Gustavo Petro y la guerrilla del
ejército de liberación nacional se
reunirá en el próximo miércoles en
Caracas así lo anunció la delegación
negociadora del grupo armado a través de
su cuenta de Twitter en el documento se
lee que la intención del encuentro será
a tratar de superar la crisis generada
cuando el presidente Petro anunció el 31
de diciembre Un cese el fuego bilateral
por seis meses sin ser acordado ni
consultado con el eln
pasamos a Estados Unidos porque se
encontraron más documentos
confidenciales en la casa del presidente
Joe biden en Delaware el hallazgo
aumenta el escrutinio sobre el
mandatario Ya que en menos de una semana
se conoció sobre el Descubrimiento de
otros dos paquetes previamente en
nuestro corresponsal en Washington
Cristóbal Vázquez nos contaba Cuál es la
percepción de los estadounidenses sobre
el tema
definitivamente esto ha tenido impacto
en la aceptación que tiene Joe biden en
el público estadounidense y muchos
tienen preguntas preguntas por ejemplo
sobre Por qué la Casa Blanca viene a
revelar hasta ahora esta información si
estos documentos se encontraron en
noviembre del año pasado y en diciembre
también por qué Por ejemplo archivos
nacionales no sabía que yo vayan tenía
estos documentos confidenciales si es la
encargada precisamente de monitorear el
manejo de información y lo que están
diciendo muchos estadounidenses es pues
que esto de alguna manera ya se vuelve
una costumbre de que expresidentes no
solamente yo vayan en este caso sino
Donald Trump recordemos hace apenas unos
meses Pues también le asignaron un
consejero especial un fiscal especial
para investigar los documentos que se
llevó amar al lago Y él precisamente
Donald Trump Pues criticó en su momento
cuando fue acusado de haberse llevado
estos documentos confidenciales de Que
Barack Obama también se había llevado
documentos confidenciales así de que lo
que piensen estadounidenses es si
precisamente llevarse documentación
clasificada de alta sensibilidad es una
tendencia de los expresidentes y del
presidente actual Joe biden en otras
noticias de Estados Unidos gran parte
del estado de California se ve
fuertemente afectado por una semana de
lluvias imparables dejando al menos 17
muertos miles de evacuados y personas
afectadas por cortes de Electricidad
Andrés triviño nos amplía
tras años de aterradoras sequías gran
parte del estado de California se ha
visto afectado durante la última semana
por el aumento entre el 400 y el 600% de
la media en sus precipitaciones causando
graves daños materiales cortes de
Electricidad y obligando a miles a
evacuar sus hogares
celo fatigados que están todos pero por
favor mantengan un poco más de
vigilancia en el transcurso de los
próximos días y superaremos esto luego
volveremos al trabajo que se debe hacer
para asegurarnos de que podamos superar
lo que está sucediendo las potentes
tormentas invernales han desatado
lluvias torrenciales vientos
inundaciones y peligrosos deslizamientos
de tierra algo que no había sucedido en
una década pero no todos son malas
noticias en el condado de Santa Bárbara
algunos de sus habitantes celebran que
el lago cachumba ha alcanzado su máximo
nivel de capacidad tras días de lluvias
incesantes generando esperanzas a un
estado que debe someterse constantemente
a racionamientos de agua por la falta de
lluvias
en 2016 el lago llegó al 6% de su
capacidad y ahora Estamos de vuelta al
100% por eso decimos que la conservación
es una forma de vida en el condado de
Santa Bárbara porque no importa si
llueve ahora Necesitamos conservar el
agua es realmente la mejor solución para
eso es que las personas asuman la
responsabilidad personal de usar menos
agua entre tanto las autoridades se
mantienen en alerta máxima para evitar
mayores desastres pero también Para
aprovechar cada gota para sobrevivir a
un verano que amenaza con causar fuertes
estragos y ha sido imposible esta semana
no Escuchar hablar de la nueva canción
de la cantante colombiana Shakira con el
productor de música urbana Argentina
bizarrap en Sólo 24 horas la canción
logró casi 64 millones de reproducciones
en YouTube aunque las letras hablan de
la relación con su expareja el
futbolista Español Gerard Piqué También
incluye referencias a varias marcas que
han sabido encontrar un impulso
previamente hablamos con Andrés Felipe
Lugo gerente de marketing de la
productora musical alta fonta
Latinoamérica
sobre lo que significa para el futuro de
la industria de la música este fenómeno
esto sin duda es el fenómeno cultural
latino para abrir el año las cifras
todavía son más grandes de la ontavas
tenemos 67 millones de virus en YouTube
en Spotify tanto en instagram vamos a
superar los 30 millones y todos los
implicados incluso las marcas fueron
trending topic en varios países a la vez
se han creado más de cuatrocientos mil
tiktoks con el audio y esto en tan solo
un plazo de dos días esto es uno de los
acontecimientos digitales más
importantes del entretenimiento en
español súper beneficioso para todos los
Implicados En el que cualquier marca si
quiere vincular esto se da por un
fenómeno de Community management que
responde ante el cruce de fenómenos
culturales que le llegan a distintas
audiencias por un lado bizarrap por otro
lado es Shakira y por el otro lado Piqué
Por qué fue tan exitoso porque se llegó
a jugar con las audiencias de los tres
que son audiencias que usualmente no
interactúan No es igual la persona que
siga Piqué que la que sigue a bizarrap
que la que sigue a girar Estos tipos de
personalidades generan pasiones muy
intensas en sus audiencias lo que llevó
a que hubiera muchos memes polémica
comentarios muy intensos y que la gente
quisiera tomar partido de esta situación
esto respondiendo tu pregunta Abre una
puerta para que estas colaboraciones
cada vez más inesperadas entre fenómenos
culturales de distintas audiencias se
den más a menudo ya el año pasado
habíamos visto algunos acercamientos
similares por ejemplo entre un Agüero y
los streamers españoles Pero con esto
creo que los números hablan por sí solos
para dar cuenta de un fenómeno sin
precedentes que supera incluso a
despacito al ser la canción con más
vistas en 24 horas
hasta aquí este informativo Gracias por
acompañarnos
[Música]